[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Volvo ah
today I have no clue what exactly I'm
gonna do as you might be able to tell my
my title what the hell is even up with
that title anyway you might be able to
tell by my title that this episode is a
little bit all over the place but if
there is one theme to be found in this
episode it is that I wanted to really
flesh out and add some finesse to the
facades which I planned in the last
episode so this really means getting to
the details of these galleries and to
these facades and getting all of those
hallways in also some stairs because the
path is quite annoying to work with
especially in the way that it's laid out
around the island and I do make sure
that that is also hooked into the
buildings so it's just a bit of general
detailing and working out the buildings
on the side here so that once I'm done
with these and the buildings are all
laid out I can actually get back into
the detailing of the island and of
course and more of a steampunk touch to
these elements as well I definitely
don't want to forget about that and I
will get into the pipes and cogs and all
of that steamy goodness at some point
later in the series again but for now I
really want to make sure that the
buildings are laid out in a good way
before we continue now a few things that
I guess I want to mention about that is
that many of these buildings will have a
different style and this is also why
these things have become so
time-consuming I know that in an earlier
episode I said that I would try to copy
things around on the island a little bit
more but I've sort of changed my mind
not entirely I still want to save as
much time on these builds as I can and
there are a few methods which I'm using
in this video is what to do so but I do
make sure that everything on this island
has a distinct look to it so that every
facade and every Tower is at least in
some very slight or subtle ways
different than the other one
on the island this should also hopefully
help to make all of these galleries and
facades look like they're differents
connected buildings rather than the
entire island just being one going with
a singular style and this is definitely
gonna end up looking quite messy but
that that kind of reflects the style as
to building the island that I'm going
for
what I just sort of realized is that the
way that I am approaching this is very
much like a doodle and in that sense
it's very different from my other
projects I am getting into the island
without much of a planning anymore
because every major thing is already
outlined and a lot of the detailing is
really just getting into the game and
doodling some stuff as though I'm
dueling the floating castle during a
boring math class that is pretty much
the approach and that is inevitably
gonna end up resulting in some of these
very random if super detailed buildings
and also the general way that the series
is being built being not so much very
organized or very systematic but really
just adding fun stuff here and there and
that's gonna be the remainder of the
episodes as well the sort of reason that
I've shifted into this approach is that
this has taken me longer than expected I
mean things are also gonna always take
longer than expected even if you take
into account that they're gonna take
longer as aspected but still I was
hoping to maybe finish this in a couple
of episodes but that was a couple of
episodes ago and by this time it really
seems like I just want to put this on
the backburner a little bit just make it
a fun little project to work on not too
much stress about it and just randomly
do it all around until we have a
finished floating island now some of the
things that I do want to mention - maybe
at least make this a bit more
interesting to you as one of the things
which I'm doing quite a lot with all of
these buildings which is something that
I don't think I ever really mentioned
before even though I do it quite a lot
in my
time-lapses is sort of copy-pasting
certain motifs around to make building
sites so for instance we have the
building that I just worked on it isn't
so much the case in the gates over here
but the building which I just worked on
for instance is really kind of built as
a layer of different motifs the first
one just being the wall that I built out
of the fountain pieces with some simple
borders around that and basically what I
usually do is to scan on a single grid
and just build the wall that I want to
make in a very simple way copy that's
with a wooden post or any grid spawning
item and this is the important part you
want to have a grid spawning item
selected as well so that you can
copy/paste that wall on the grid and
basically copy-paste that around until
you have the shape of the building and
the only then I actually make the
pillars and after the pillars were done
did the same thing added a wooden
pillory somewhere or a gates any kind of
building piece that spawns a grid to
basically copy those pillars as a sort
of motif around the building and the
same finally also went for some of the
Bennis traits and what this makes sure
is also that you can always change the
things a little bit afterwards so as you
might have noticed I changed the
balustrade at the beginning of this
episode and all I really did was copied
it gates along with my new balustrade
copied that gate and the balustrade
around and removed all of the extra
gates that I placed as a result of that
which basically makes sure that you can
seamlessly copy your like new little
addition or your new change to what you
already had around without having to
worry about the exact placement actually
fitting because it's still on the grid
and afterwards just remove your grid
spawning piece that's something that I
do very often though I don't I barely
ever really put any attention into how I
do it in some cases it's a little bit
more tricky as I'm still running behind
and you might have just noticed that
with the dome I also changed the bottom
of the dome a little bit and this means
that for changing the bottom of the dome
I had to use the same technique then I
I used to make the dome itself which is
the place to scenery pieces on both ends
of a wooden post and then remove the
post in the end
select both scenery pieces on both sides
and rotate the entire thing if that
makes any sense it is quite complicated
but if you really want to know the
details of that occur watch my planet
Costa College video on domes because
it's explaining there but basically I'm
changing quite a lot of the details
which I've made in early episodes and by
kind of working systematically in that
sense you're at least always able to
slightly adjust some of the things that
you've built earlier so that's probably
all so what are we doing quite a lots
also over here with the bottom of the
building I was figuring I wanted to have
something interesting and not just a
straight flat wall though that said the
bottom of the island is currently my
biggest struggle because I have no idea
what to do with that thing yet and I
might also require some kind of input
from you guys on what I should do with
the bottom of the island right now I am
pretty much gravitating toward living in
rocks and putting shrubbery around it
maybe having some vines hanging
underneath and kind of decorate it that
way I might also just make it a full
metal sort of skin or wooden skin we'll
see what happens with that at some point
but for now I'm trying to connect these
buildings as fleshly as I can to the
bottom of the island and in some cases
that really means sort of extending the
bottoms outward a bit with these
diagonal elements then I'm also kind of
doing that over here in this case since
even these these walls over here I did
want to have them stick out a bit I
guess I was cheating a little bit with
the gallery on the left side here since
I literally copied that from the Front's
of the island as you might have
remembered from one of the earlier
episodes but it fits in pretty much
perfectly over there so I'm still quite
happy with that and I guess the reason
then I also want to talk about that I
added all of these galleries and these
very horizontal sort of elements of
buildings on the side of the dome here
is that I also wanted to prevent the
island from becoming just a spam of
towers it definitely looks very much
like a Disney castle from the front and
from the back where all the towers sort
of zoom into one line and it ends up
looking like a Disneyland castle but I
did want to avoid that Disney Castle
look for this island as much as I can
the thing is a Disney Castle is just not
how a real castle is a real castle has
often some towers and carnival
decoration to it but it also packs some
body to it and some actual so make sure
insights and I have to kind of do that
with Favara as well because I have the
coaster running through it and the
entire island has to sort of be built
around the coaster so there simply isn't
any room for an account list hours and
making this island into one big Disney
Castle because that would just
inevitably turn it into a giant mess of
towers and that's something that I don't
want to do though and that's also why I
want to have some of these much more
horizontal sort of humble like accents
in the galleries on the side of the of
the island but also this walkway bridge
on the side here which was quite
interesting because I wanted to get away
from the standard look that the parts
give you but obviously working around
the paths with those curves and with the
stairs isn't really the easiest thing so
this was quite a struggle to get this in
in a way that would not just kind of
cover up the paths as they look in game
but also be able to connect this pathway
to the rest of the island and at the
same time make sure that the coaster
could pass underneath it and give an
interesting head chopper so in the end I
just decided to go with a collection of
different objects that should hopefully
be a bit more flexible than just simple
war pieces so while the war pieces are
definitely doing quite okay for the
straight section especially with some of
the Battlement pieces many of the war
pieces here are again scenery pieces
that are made to be more pieces because
they're much more flexible
and this definitely also sort of limits
your choice as to what taxes you can
actually use which can be quite annoying
at times but I would really recommend
trying out to make walls made out of
scenery pieces as I've done a few times
in this series already since if you
really need to they can give you much
more like different shapes especially in
cases like this for instance
I needed that sort of diagnol piece for
the bottom of the stairway and there is
no such piece in the actual wall pieces
but there is the there is one of those
gothic pieces which does have the brick
piece on it or the brick texture on it
and that is just a standalone object and
a wall so you can actually rotate that
in any direction so you can make a wall
out of that and actually make it diagnol
and rotate it in any direction or even
shape arches and towers of it in your
own kind of shape and size so really
making walls out of objects is one of my
favourite things right now and there is
a lot of potential in that the only
thing I guess that you should be worried
of is the fact that they're gonna
inevitably add quite a bit of lag figure
came after quite a while so do be
careful with those things and obviously
there is somewhat time consuming to make
as well but making custom walls is just
always quite nice because many of the
textures that you do have in the walls
come back in some way in some of the
objects that we have obviously to make
sure that the objects work well with the
wall pieces but at the same time this
means that we can actually make our own
wall pieces and that is always awesome
though I have to say yeah it is
different from the sense that the walls
that I made earlier in this series also
kind of used the objects in a different
way and that they added textures to the
walls that the in-game malls don't have
so some of these towers for instance but
also the rectangular building over the
station building itself are using a
texture of the back of a fountain piece
because it's a slightly darker gray
me thank you but it doesn't have a sense
than texture to it and it's a texture
that you can't find on any of the walls
in game but this object does have it so
making a wall out of that object sort of
fills that lack of wall with that
texture which can be quite handy and you
can there's a lot that you can
experiment with when it comes to that
kind of stuff and I'm just working on
some of the finishing touches of the
bridge here one of my biggest struggles
personally is finishing stuff up in such
a way that they are actually looking
clean and there aren't too many bits
that are looking ugly or awkward and I
guess just like bob ross said there are
such things as happy mistakes no that
wasn't it anyway sometimes a mistake can
be turned into something that actually
works in the end so for instance on the
curve of the bridge there I wasn't able
to get rid of like the way that the
stones were coming through each other
but you might as well work with that at
least trying to make the entire thing
look as clean as possible and go with
whatever look you can't fix and also I
wanted to very quickly get into the
detailing of the tower here because at
that point I was just looking at the
tower and it was looking still pretty
naked on this side over here and I
figured might as well add a bit of
detail to that already get into that
again and I will be detailing a lot of
the island in a very similar way to this
just adding a bunch of pipes and
machinery especially on the insights
though of the castle where the coaster
is gonna have more interaction with the
scenery I hope to get more machinery and
machinery I was sorry I hope to get more
of you know you know esteem and cog
wheels everything I hope to get more
moving parts and interesting bits to
look at but for the tower for the time
being
pipes and cables to make everything look
a bit more gritty industrial and
purposefully messy should hopefully work
to make it fit in a little bit more with
what's around it
but then again and in those smaller
details are really some of the things
that I can only do once the entire area
is done because until that points I
really want to make sure that the
buildings are done in a way that I'm
happy with it and that works out before
I actually get into the actual detailing
of it which is something that I would
stress in any case is really important
always make sure that you have your
general look of the building before you
get into the detailing not just because
it's much easier to change your building
once it's not completely detailed yet
and it's really hard to like slightly
change the dimensions or the positions
of buildings once you've already got
everything including the detailing in
but also because it can be very easy to
lose sight of the bigger picture once
your detailing and this is personally I
think one of the biggest traps and what
makes detailing somewhat of a simple
thing actually but that one that can be
kind of dangerous because looking too
much into detailing can just make you
lose sight of the bigger picture and end
up with buildings that might be super
detailed but not fit into the entire
sort of picture that you were looking
for in the first place and beside
another thing then I would like to
mention is that there is such a thing as
too much detailing there definitely is
while this project in itself is trying
to go for like that sort of grotesque
amount detailing and ridiculously small
things everywhere you don't really
notice detail unless there are areas
which are less detailed and you see this
back in so many things like some
European architecture where the walls
might be super detailed
but then the roofs are less detailed or
on the other hand in Asian architecture
where sometimes the roofs are extremely
detailed and fill up a large section of
the building with walls that are much
more drawn back and less detailed you
want to make sure that the details that
you do bringing really come out and
stick out from their surroundings so not
just the amount of detail is important
but also the way that your
it's make sure that there are some less
detailed areas and some detailed areas
that really throw your eyes towards it
that would be my general take on things
anyway with that little sidestep into
detailing I want to conclude this video
so thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you